[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es auch bei einem kanal
fuchtel ich liebe ja pusteln und bucht
und das ist ein hefegebäck mit einer
füllung heute gibt's weihnachtliche
punkte ich habe nämlich den hefeteig mit
zehn zubereitet und darin verfügt sich
eine orangenmarmelade dich selbst
gemacht habe und die buchungen die sind
einfach immer super lecker so viel zu
den wurzeln am ende dieses videos gibt's
übrigens unter anderem eine
küchenmaschine zu gewinnen aber zum
gewinnspiel sagte später am ende noch
ein bisschen mehr
jetzt bereiten wir erst einmal den
hefeteig sohn ich zeige euch die zutaten
für den teig verwende ich einen würfel
hefe 160 gramm zucker 3 esslöffel wasser
500 milliliter milch vier eigelbe ein
kilo mehl einen teelöffel salz zwei
teelöffel zimt und 240 g weiche butter
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die hefe die wird
ein bisschen zerbröselt geht sie direkt
in die küchenmaschine
normalerweise nehme ich für ein halbes
kilo mehl auch einen würfel hefe startet
sie einfach den teig länger auf gehen
aber wir können natürlich auch zwei
büffel hilfe nehmen die gebe ich jetzt
noch den zucker dazu dann das wasser
richtig zupacken kurz vor ihr
gebe ich hier die eigelbe dazu mehl und
salz kann ich jetzt ein bisschen
verrühren und ich habe jetzt hier
dinkelmehl ihr könnt aber natürlich auch
weizenmehl benutzen dann kommt ihr die
milch dazu die geräusche das sind
übrigens die handwerker oben
die hole ich dann später einfach zum
probieren dazu die machen gerade noch
das bad sind kommt mit den teig und
jetzt kann ich den teig schon mal
verkneten und dann langsam noch die
butter dazugeben
jetzt ist der teig fertig und erst
richtig schön geschmeidig
ich nehme mir jetzt hier mal heraus dann
einfach zu einer kugel formen jetzt
fertig die schüssel wenig das neue
element km jetzt kommt die teig kugel
hier wieder rein
ich kann sie abdecken und dann wird war
eine stunde auf gehen lassen bis sie
sich verdoppelt hat und den derzeit
mache ich schon mal meine
orangenmarmelade
für die orangenmarmelade verwende ich
ein kilo orangenfilets 75 gramm zucker
200 milliliter orangensaft 400 gramm
zucker das ist der drei zu eins zucker
etwas vanille extrakt sternanis und eine
zimtstange jetzt nimm dir die orangen
und filetiert dafür wird jetzt erstmal
hier oben der deckel weg geschnitten
dann der boden und dann die seitenteile
so dass einfach die weiße haut entfernt
wird jetzt nämlich die orange in die
hand geht über ein großes gefäß und das
habe ich jetzt hier auf eine waage
gestellt und hier wirklich dann ein kino
ab also eigentlich orangenfilets
inklusive saft jetzt könnt ihr hier mit
dem messer rechts und links einschneiden
ganz vorsichtig dass er diese trennwand
dazwischen und die filets herauslösen
und die weiße trennwand die bleibt übrig
den rest könnt ihr dann einfach noch mit
der hand auspressen
da darf nichts verschwendet wird
jetzt sind wir auch rauschend filetiert
und ich kann jetzt den zucker also den
normalen zucker hier in einem großen
topf karamellisieren lassen
und wenn ihr auch so saftige orangen hat
braucht ihr den zusätzlichen orangensaft
gar nicht dann nehmt ihr einfach 1,2
kilo orangen felix mit saft den zucker
hier drin jetzt bei hoher stufe
karamellisieren lassen sobald der zucker
karamellisiert ist wird er jetzt
abgelöst mit dem orangensaft
jetzt bildet sich ein großer karamell
klumpen aber der löst sich jetzt in dem
orangensaft oder schön auf dadurch
bekommen wir jetzt noch richtig schönen
karamell ihren geschmack in die
marmelade
ich kann jetzt hier auch schon mal die
orangenfilets dazu geben inklusive saft
echt einer meiner lieblings marmeladen
die orangenmarmelade dann kommen hier
auch die gewürze rein zimtstange drei
sternanis etwas vanille extrakt
und dann noch der zucker und hier nehme
ich immer den drei zu eins zucker damit
die marmelade einfach nicht so süß wird
jetzt alles kurz verrühren und dann so
etwa fünf bis sechs minuten kochen
lassen
die marmelade dürfte jetzt 5 minuten
kochen
und ich habe jetzt hier einen esslöffel
ungefähr auf einen kleinen teller
gegeben und den kühlschrank gestellt so
mache ich nämlich immer gerne chalepo
und wenn die fest wird dann wird die
ganze marmelade fest jetzt will ich die
marmeladengläser ab und verschließe sie
und lasst sie fest werden ich habe jetzt
einfach ein bisschen mehr gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist ein hefeteig richtig schön
aufgegangen
ich glaube ich denn hier auf meine
arbeitsplatte hefeteig hat einfach was
meditativ ist und ich hätte jetzt
einfach die hände mit bisschen rücktritt
spray und kann das jetzt schon mal
funktionieren so etwa 30 punkten werden
das je nachdem wie ihr sie machen wollt
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch kleiner
oder größer machen
[Applaus]
die marmelade ist jetzt auch schon fest
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach einen teig in
die hand dann formt sie den bisschen
auseinander
wie kommt ein bisschen normal laden die
miete nicht so wenig mir nicht zu viel
und dann schön drumherum verschließen so
dass die marmelade nicht ausräumen dann
vor sich gespannt und die fuchtel nehme
ich dann hier in einem backblech
städtchen ganz großes immer jedes gleich
die menge reicht aber offenen programmen
für einen großen wir können sich auch
die hälfte machen und einfach einen
kleinen tortenring bei thun das blech
das fertig jetzt ein bisschen und dann
liegt hier alle rundherum rennen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nämlich dass sie zu mir ich habe
ungefähr zweieinhalb gläser gebraucht
von der marmelade also allzu kritisch
jetzt bestreitet die viertel noch mit
flüssiger butter und dann könnt ihr sie
entweder noch mal abdeckungen aufgehen
lassen für eine halbe stunde oder ihr
stellte dann in den karton packen macht
dann den ofen an und können sie dann
doch dann brauchen so etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten länger wachsen aber während der
backofen dann auf heißt können die
buchten daneben noch mal auf gehen und
wenn ich sie richtig lecker und wut
haben wollt könnt ihr dann noch kampflos
das leben wenn ihr ein backofen mit
dampf und habt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rufen an und bank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die buchten sind gebacken und ich lasse
ganz kurz abkühlen
jetzt kommen wir zum gewinnspiel zu
gewinnen gibt's zum einen die
küchenmaschine die kenwood cent in ihrer
lieblingsfarbe
ihr könnt einen backtag mit mir gewinnen
und zehn mal das tennis classics back
hoch und diese backbücher die werde ich
für euch hab zu gehen und wenn ihr beim
gewinnspiel mitmachen wollt dann macht
einfach ein weihnachts rezeptor
lieblingsrezept vielleicht auch aus der
kindheit oder was ihr gerne mit euren
kindern eurem ehepartner oder eurer
freundin bugs das rezept schießt ein
foto davon und dadurch das rezept mit
dem bild dann im fanclub hoch und dort
gibt es auch schon drei meiner lieblings
weihnachts rezepte zu sehen und mit
etwas glück seid ihr dann unter den
gewinnern
die warmen fuchteln habe ich jetzt noch
mit glitzer schnee bestreut und jetzt
dürfen die mail abonnieren
[Applaus]
die handwerker sind zwar nicht mehr da
aber ich habe andere fahrgast der
einzigste man die anderen jungs einzig
der einzige tut mir leid das ist nämlich
es gibt keine einzige einzig ist einzig
und einzigste geht nichts mehr ist kein
superlativ sein wechsel ist noch eine
steigerung
ich bin der einzigste einzige einzel wir
machen hier kommt ein junge 8 warum ist
der einzige der so klein hier ist
natürlich ganz schön
die stiegl frank tatsächlich aus wie ein
kleiner bruder
ok so jung ich hab doch gesagt kann ich
das ja macros annehmen weil auch schon
ungleich geführt
acht frauen immer gern gesehen hat heute
die mutter angezogen probier also kein
weizenmehl wieder fit wird
die orangen oder was sagt ihr dazu
super und zimt sternanis die orange mal
dasselbe gemacht ja hammer
was meinst gas wasserinstallateur
vergleich das gleich mitnehmen ja machen
wir auch beständigkeit bin ich deswegen
eine höhere macht mich super ja weil sie
das rezept nach machen wollt schaut ganz
genau
und ja ansonsten machte einfach im
winter von poster ist und wir schauen
uns ins amt ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim gewinnspiel genau hin wieviel
maschinen wir nicht gegen leute vorbei
und machte mich nachgeschnitten nicht
bestechen ehrlich jetzt bist du ja kein
fake sie sagen die wahrheit alles offen
also bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]
halt stopp ich muss vorwurf machen komm
mit 1 2 1 1 im sommer bilder machen was
ist drin geht nicht gleich nach dem foto
halbe stunde ok halbe stunde auf halbe
stunde und dann gebe ich dir das ganze
gleich okay man dürfe das vernichten
also viel spaß viel glück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
an